[Musica]
mi chiedo quando la parola integrazione
è diventata fuga di cervelli
dopo aver ascoltato chi l'ha preceduto
temo che aprono col tema vi sedete
cominciamo subito con un piccolo filmato
tratto dal film nuovo cinema paradiso
che ci fa vedere la situazione
nell'immediato né io né come hai visto
cinematografici
attimi torna di dieci tu si gioca il
mondo e io sono vecchio
quello più seguito le gare vecchio
sempre mandare in idee
non ci pensiamo noi non ti voltare lo
scrive da fare contro in mano a questa
gente dimentica cinotti se non resiste e
torna indietro i giovani di face italia
capiente ho capito
ecco cosa per me
farei come amava la cabina del paradiso
e belli vicenda
[Musica]
eccolo
o
da allora è cambiata la situazione in
italia in calabria
probabilmente anche peggiorato come
cercherò di sottolineare al mio
intervento
intanto premetto che la mia è stata la
fuga del cervello è stata una semplice
esperienza a destra e esperienza che
ormai vanta da cinquant'anni quindi
probabilmente le cose sono cambiate da
allora milano in fisica nel 1966 e come
tutti i laureati e universitario a di
allora laureati che di euro
la grande europea della scuola romana di
fisica di enrico fermi tutti sognavamo
di andare in america vista europee
la nuova frontiera della scienza della
ricerca
io ci andai nel 69 con una borsa di
studio fulbright un programma del
governo americano che offriva borse di
studio agli studenti meritevoli di tutto
il mondo che volessero sugli anelli
necessità dell'italia quindi una prima
riflessione d'ordine generale è la
seguente east arditi allora anche adesso
puntano tutto sul kart a roma e ci
mettevano punti e altre risorse per
azzate da menti di digiuno talenti molti
dei quali sarebbero ritornati
dai loro paesi altri invece sarebbero
rimasti un'altra modalità di assistenza
finanziaria degli stati uniti era
offerto la biodiversità delicato per la
parte privata fino all'assistenza
finanziaria per il pagamento delle
enormi tasse messi varie che si pagano
lì le cosiddette sui phillies
per essere ammessi doveva fare una
domanda e mandare alcune leggi sopra le
comande chance così diceva letteralmente
del modulo
io venga citato in tre differenti
università quella di scadenza quella di
posto e frustatori ora sceso quella di
new york perché interessano a lavorare
certo professore il professor canton un
astrofisico che insegnava quello che
visitano mi racconto breve episodio
relativo alle lettere di raccomandazione
che in italiano sono molto brutto sembra
una cosa bruttissima mentre in america e
in altri ambienti una cosa molto seria
vanno dal professor messico di fisica
teorica l'esame dovrà aver avuto 30 è
per lui una lettera di una nazione era
una cosa sacra
un impegno d'onore il professore mi
rifiuta di iscrivervi la ventana
dicendomi che per avere all'interno
della
la nazionale va ben altro di un 30
d'esame
occorreva la partitura una maggiore
conoscenza del mio carattere delle di
attitudine delle mie aspirazioni
se lo ricorda distanza di 50 anni
la cosa deve essere ma stavolta
interessa io non consegua usa ancora per
questo rifiuto anzi ritengo che per me
sia stato e sia rimasto un grande
insegnamento per fortuna il centro che
solo lombarda dicembre c'e una bella
lettera che insieme alle altre contenta
al professore che aiutarono a essere
accettato in università quindi la mia
testa riflessione di carattere generale
in seguente una lettera di
raccomandazione un'anticipazione
certificato hanno significati diversi
luoghi diversi in abiti diversi in modi
diversi
pensate ai 900 certificati medici che
hanno consentito al novecento vigili
urbani di roma di assentarsi dal lavoro
la notte di san silvestro
per capire quant'è importante che
certifica la mia esperienza americana ne
sono stato per più di tre anni poi sono
andato tantissime volte per seguire i
programmi spaziali è stata molto
significativa sia sui piani di scudi sia
su quello dell'osservazione di un'altra
società altro voto sul caso degli
studios seguiti cozzi che mi avrebbero
portato allora segmento del titolo in
the city il dottorato americano titolo
che all'epoca non esisteva nel nostro
ordinamento del sipario sul carro della
ricerca di sono un paio di un argomento
oggi proprio oggi molto attuale ma che
almeno vent'anni sano o ti l'origine del
sistema solare
oggi abbiamo evidenza sperimentale di
centinaia di pianeti che orbitano
intorno alla loro stella e ci si chiede
se in alcuni di essi ci possono essere
forme di vita simile a quella esistente
sul pianeta terra
negli anni sessanta tutta questa
problematica non esisteva e mi sento
privilegiato per aver avuto modo di
riflettere sui temi così importanti con
un certo anticipo rispetto agli altri
sul campo dell'osservazione di un altro
mondo
racconto questo episodio per avere
l'installazione di marina telefonica in
italia dovrebbe aspettare qualche mese
quindi la comandare a qualche santo
qualche dubbio che agevolava in america
bastava fare una telefonata alla
compagnia dei telefoni dopo quello a
dire di latina trent d'arby altre
considerazioni di carattere generale
perché per fare una cosa che in america
ci muoiono due giorni in italia ci
vorranno sei mesi riflessione che ne
porta con sé molte altre
sull'organizzazione del lavoro sul ruolo
dei sindacati sull'uomo del merito della
democrazia anzi della merito calzino sul
mondo delle procedure e in italia e sul
podio riempimento di le moduli mentre in
america basta una telefonata e sam alla
installazione di marina telefonica si
passa all'organizzazione della ricerca
scientifica
le riflessioni si fanno più importanti e
più complesse
all'epoca i fisici eravamo terrorizzati
dall'idea di rimanere disoccupati dopo
tanti anni di studio e una disciplina
così difficile a meno bene perché riuscì
a tra le università che poi sono rimasti
ho fatto gran parte della
la carriera ma oggi che fa
all'università o comunque la politica
universitaria per incoraggiare i giovani
talenti alì marina di campo della
ricerca dell'innovazione
non so se l'avete osservato che per me
politica di di ricerca innovazione sono
un po qualcosa di equivalente a politica
dei giovani rispondere a questi
interrogativi ci porterebbe troppo
lontano
dovremo passare al politica farebbe
analisi delle nostre scelte politiche
cosa che ovviamente non farò perché
quest'anno nella sede però lasciata di
fare una sola osservazione di natura
politica anche se estremamente
estremamente sintetica posso avere la
seconda slide la prima slide anzi
risale a mostrare la tabella
eccola qua dove si dice che l'italia
aspetta per le pensioni 17 per cento del
suo pil mentre nei paesi ocse si spende
all 8,7 in italia spendiamo per la spesa
in ricerca e sviluppo all 1,3 mentre la
media dei paesi ocse 2 recato questa
tabella vale più di mille riscossi
mostra quali sono le nostre scelte
politiche
l'italia è un paese per vecchi
contrariamente agli altri paesi con i
quali ci confrontiamo l'italia dedica
alla spesa per le pensioni una
percentuale doppia rispetto agli altri e
questo naturalmente ci impedisce di
dedicare le risorse necessarie alla
ricerca era subito orario indizio di
questa mia osservazione e al mio parere
l'enorme debito pubblico che abbiamo che
in pratica significa far pagare alle
prossime generazioni
ciò che ci ha garantito le ore di vita
superiore a livello che ci potevano
prenderlo
questo sia a livello nazionale che a
livello locale
quasi tutti i nostri comuni sono
indebitati perché le nostre
amministrazioni pur di acquistare il
consenso si sposto fanno dei pc che
saranno pagati da altri
la riflessione politica e andiamo avanti
la mia esperienza americana gli fa
incontrare il professore serve colombo
un grandissimo scienziato del settore
spaziale che introduce nel settore delle
attività spaziali settore da cui non
sono mai uscito fino poi aumentare vice
presidente dell'agenzia spaziale
italiana è successivamente presidente di
due importanti società del gruppo
finmeccanica
ora leonardo incarico che lo sfotto fino
a due anni fa
come avete notato ho fatto spesso
riferimento ai miei professori perché
forse la mia teoria ma nella vita di
ognuno di noi ci sono autori incontri
che segnano la dualità e che per me sono
stati quelli tra citato il professor
camera viene avviata la ricerca
scientifica il professor colombo che mi
ha introdotto del mondo per lo spazio e
la nostra vita ci sono altri punti di
riferimento importanti il primo luogo i
tuoi genitori che ti hanno dato la vita
poi forse la tua compagna che ti andava
punito la compagnia
poi ci sono i professori dalla
conoscenza
[Musica]
io vorrei citare anche quelli del liceo
basta per l'utente dinamo 30 per questo
motivo io dico quasi sempre a 20 giovani
di fare un'esperienza all'estero perché
quasi sempre conoscere mondi e società
ad essere un arricchimento quasi sempre
ci saranno
un maggior numero di opportunità di
scegliere un maggior numero di oltre che
segnerà un aboliva è anche una maggiore
capacità di valutazione della società da
cui proviene
ma naturalmente c'è una bella differenza
fra scegliere di fare un'esperienza
all'estero
nel mio caso è una fuga all'estero per
necessità perché il tuo territorio
ti offre alcuna opportunità di lavoro
c'è una bella differenza fanali via da
roma o da milano e ad allievo alla
calabria
chi va via dalla calabria quasi mai di
torna quindi io succede email
organizzatori di questo contempo pero
prossimo tel
il problema debito perché il problema
della fuga non è pronto
e il problema del problema chi va via
dalla calabria segna una testa se catena
imparabile per la regione l'emigrazione
dei primi del novecento o del secondo
dopoguerra riguardava barbieri i suoni
di sarti e altro personale non
qualificati opera l'emigrazione riguarda
ingegneri medici informatici economisti
ed altri figure altamente professionali
come farà la galanti a sopravvivere
senza ossigeno rappresentato da questo
capitale umano
non lo so proprio con riferimento alla
calabria il problema di cervelli in fuga
sulle produzioni di non è solo tipico
moltissimi sono i giovani dominati e
forse anche milioni che lasciano qanat
operata da ballare al cuore che fa la
cavagna oppure che hanno potuto fare per
di una cava altre persone come ti hanno
avuto l'opportunità di fare molte cose
io ci ho provato ma non ci sono riuscito
perche la calabria ed i trattati
ogni cagnolino puoi avere in tasca tre
premi nobel
ma se non hai un pacchetto di volta
offrire sono ottimi
in calabria come forse ne hanno più
bisogno nessuna ricerca di talenti ma ti
valutano solo per il mondo figure
portale ho tentato in un paio di persone
che avanzare alcune proposte ma ahimè
non ci sono riuscito quando ero vice
presidente dell'agenzia spaziale
italiana unesco da 800 milioni di budget
ho tentato di promuovere un ancora fra
la stessa agenzia e la regione calabria
ancora che fu poi firmato nel 2000 e che
prevedeva un comitato congiunto tra tre
esperti dell'agenzia vari esperti della
nazione calabria
questo comitato non si è mai riunito per
l'inerzia della regione calabria
successivamente il mantello presidente
nella società e geos la disciplina e
società italiana di osservazione della
terra attraverso dati satellitari ed
aereo aveva proposto la dimensione di
società mista congiunta fra la stessa
icharus e la regione calabra ritenendo
che il territorio della regione con il
suo dissesto idrogeologico
il suo inquinamento costiera e non sulla
storia di sotterramento dei rifiuti
illegali avesse bisogno simile non se ne
fece nulla anche se su questo tentativo
aveva avuto l'appoggio sincero e
convinto dell'allora avventore
l'università senza professore la torre
nella vicina basilicata alle porte di
matera e invito ad andarci se passavano
per farti c'è un certo spaziale di
interesse internazionale
chi passa da quelle parti non crede al
signor vedendo centinaia realt ente che
scontano il cielo e che ricevono i dati
dei vari satelliti di osservazione della
terra che mi mettano prima immagini
grezze poi immagini elaborate poi
immagine interpretate per i vari campi
di pagine dalla geologia all'agricoltura
la mappatura del solo occupa centinaia
di persone che crea un indotto di
altrettante centinaia di persone volevo
fare qualcosa del genere in calante
senza riuscirci concludo con tre
riflessioni
se volete a mare intanto concludo
dicendo le giovani organizzatevi con le
vostre proprie forze non aspettatevi
niente dalla politica
l'italia non investe quando dovrebbe
invece restare dove l'italiano di test e
nei giovani talenti
anzi lascia loro l'onere del pagamento
del debito cumulato l'italia e la
calabria in particolare non ha un serio
programma di incentivazione per far
ritornare i giovani che dopo aver
maturato preziosa esperienza all'estero
poteva
tra importanti d'italia quanto acquisito
loro vorrei fare i complimenti
all'organizzazione di tempo perché
attraverso convegni come questo si può
discutere dal basso su argomenti di
questa la dura così importanti grazie
[Applauso]